bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
alors cette semaine dans le kiosque nous
partirons à la recherche des reliques
perdues à saint quentin en yvelines et
licola gervais nous présentera la
nouvelle saison du prisme mais pour
l'heure place à nos invités
les 28 et 29 juin ils seront plus de 300
musiciens amateurs à versailles à
l'occasion de la huitième édition du
concours international de fanfares nous
en parlerons ce soir avec l'un des
membres organisateurs soir vincent
lefort le soir vous êtes venu accompagné
de deux représentants des fanfares
versaillaise florence david et baptiste
jamra bonsoir à tous les deux laure
vincent comment va se dérouler ce
week-end qu'elle sera donc la
programmation qu'on en finisse et une
rencontre de deux fanfares sur le thème
d'un concours et on va accueillir une
vingtaine de groupes qui viennent de
france et d'ailleurs
mais parce que c'est internationale wes
a pour vocation d'être un à
l'international donc on a quelques
fanfares invitées qui viennent qui
viennent d'europe débat et puis servi
donc l'europe élargie aux quels sont les
genres musicaux présentés alors c'est
très éclectique
la fanfare on a un peu tout puisque le
principe
enfin la plupart des fanfares font des
reprises et elle pioche dans le
répertoire moderne
l'ancien fonds peut on retrouve vraiment
de tout dans le milieu des fanfares donc
c'est de la musique de rue cuivre et
voilà parce qu'on peut être rappeler ce
qu'il faut faire
ouais alors une sans fard c'est une
formation
devant exclusivement on trouve
essentiellement des cuivres quelques
bois blanche des saxos c'est plus rare
dans les formations lacombe a invité
mais on trouve quelques unes des
formations traditionnelles depuis
ouais alors c'est trompette trombone
tuba soubassophone batterie
principalement et puis après on a des
formations qui élargissent ça sur
d'autres d'autres vend donc ça peut être
clarinette saxo flûte
après on va retrouver les puristes c'est
pas l'écrire s'est placée alors c'est un
concours c'est le thème en tout cas que
vous donnez à cet événement pour autant
c'est surtout un moment d'échangé de
rencontre ouais tout à fait alors c'est
un concours parce que rien il y aura un
jury exactement donc en fait on a une
organisation où on promène les fanfares
dans la ville de versailles dans le
centre ville samedi après midi tout à
fait donc là c'est vraiment un moment de
rencontre avec le public c'est les
français jouent leur répertoire et se
promène dans la ville sur différentes
podium alors je vais peut-être autres à
six essais de 10h30 à 14h il mieux c'est
d'aller voir site internet pour voir les
points de l'exacte e mans c'est ça et le
soir et donc le soir passez en mode
concours est donc là chaque fonds phare
15 minutes pour faire pour présenter
deux morceaux avec une mise en scène est
effectivement un jour devant un jury
qu'est-ce qu'il sera important
alors là on évalue la justesse musical
on évalue la mise en scène
heureusement donc voilà sur des critères
on n'est pas que sur le critère musicale
la fanfare c'est vraiment le principe
ces musiques de rue ça doit interagir
avec le public et la mise en scène c'est
très important et la spécificité
également c'est que c'est un concours
tournant le grand gagnant organise
l'édition suivante en gagnant à
l'honneur d'organiser les éditions si je
comprends bien vous même vous avez gagné
l'année dernière et nous on a gagné
l'année dernière donc avec la fanfare
délicat le web et fait l'organisation
cette année est donc l'année prochaine
notre gagnant organisera le concours
également qu'est ce qui est important qu
est ce que vous souhaitez montrer au
public parce que c'est un gros pain un
regroupement entre vous tous ça c'est
bien
et pas publics qu'est-ce qui alors qu'il
va pouvoir voir pour le public c'est
d'abord on fait de la musique qui quand
on fait de la musique cherche à
interagir avec quelqu'un donc pour nous
le public c'est moyen d'interagir avec
le et la fanfare c'est la musique de rue
c'est on est en général très proche du
public non qui verra un moment festif un
moment des changes et a besoin de lui
réalmont la référence vous vous jouez
vous jouez pardon du tuba au sein de la
fanfare les mustangs
qu'est ce qui vous a donné envie
d'intégrer sage alors en fait les
fanfares faut un peu remettre un point
de vue historique c'est une et des
beaux-arts de paris
et quand les écoles darchy se sont créés
il ya
mattel un peu plus de temps en temps
quand même maman cette tradition a
perduré dans les écoles darchy de france
à versailles en a beaucoup
l'école voilà moi je l'avais bien dit
versailles et chaque année des fanfares
secret à versailles par promotion
normalement ou alors par groupes d'amis
et donc moi j'ai intégré les mustangs il
ya neuf ans maintenant que les miss tant
que ça à 10 ans et c'était un petit
groupe de nanas qui ont décidé de
continuer cette tradition avait pas que
des filles
on n'est que des filles une section
cuivre est exactement épié défis alors
les fondatrices
il y en a plus beaucoup aujourd'hui il
en reste cinq six des premières qui
vivent ici la fanfare ça a beaucoup
évolué au fil des ans des nouvelles sont
arrivées on est plus que architectes non
plus maintenant on a aussi d'autres
formats laisse faire on a ouvert en fait
une fois que le diplôme d'architecturé
passé d'affaires parfois un peu un autre
rythme et
on habite à paris on travaille donc
c'est ça devient autre chose
vous est-il musiciens et non alors je
n'étais pas vraiment musicienne alors
comment alors les fanfarons ne semble
pas forcément musiciens à la base n'ont
pas fait forcément des grandes d'amener
au conservatoire on apprend un peu
ensemble
en fait moi je suis arrivé après un an
de la création des mustangs et il
manquait un tuba et voilà on m'a dit tu
vas faire du tuba nucléaire et comment
on fait et ben on nous apprend en fait
c'est ça qui est bien c'est que c'est un
groupe on apprend tout ensemble on
apprend à jouer à utiliser cet
instrument à l'écouté à savoir s'en
servir et progressivement a vraiment
vraiment sentir à l'aise dans son
instrument pouvoir faire des solos et
continuer à progresser les nouvelles qui
arrivent sont à nouveau fort mais voilà
ça soit un petit peu comme ça elle
cotait encore une fois la main du
partage et ça chacun à son niveau donc
il ya des filles qui sont peut-être plus
musicienne qui vont écrire les morceaux
qui vont plus s'investir dans ce domaine
là c'est chacun à son niveau et ce
soutien pour faire de beaux morceaux et
moi je vous propose c'est qu'on regarde
tout de suite un extrait pour voir l'une
de leurs prestations
m
or baptisme vous êtes tromboniste au
sein de la fanfare godfinger vous aussi
vous êtes issu un ancien l'école d'archi
de versailles
vous aussi vous n'aviez pas de formation
pour autant comment on peut définir
votre seigneur qu'elle est qu'elle
estime musicale même pour la petite
histoire moi j'ai travaillé au même
endroit que fluence en fait dans les
ateliers de l'école d'archi de
versailles donc j'aurais voulu rentrer
chez mustang mais vous aurez pourquoi
j'ai pas pu être possible
du coup je suis entré dans une autre
fanfare des grottes fingers
donc c est une fanfare giresse que j'ai
intégré il ya six ans où ça joue un peu
de tout ça peut jouer des morceaux des
années 80 jusqu'à mi cas où ça va aussi
un atelier l'amour et la violence
donc c'est toujours des reprises comme
on adapte ses reprises
c'est pas forcément évident pour ça
qu'on est toujours content d'avoir un ou
deux musiciens alors on peut trouver des
partitions de l'aja préétabli souvent
des fanfares ont déjà écrit certains
morceaux peut leur demander s'ils
peuvent nous les passé pour qu'on puisse
un peu continuer à perdurer cette
musique et c'est grâce à ça que ça
continue l'improvisation et y en a alors
c'est pas toujours très beau parce que
mais c'est un peu le but justement quand
on n'a pas appris la musique au
conservatoire on n'ose pas en général
justement faire un peu d'improvisation
alors qu'en fait finalement
on se retrouve par exemple à faire un
boeuf non en fin de soirée avec d'autres
sans fard et c'est là qu'on fait on
commence à travailler avec l'oreille et
que ça devient aussi intéressant et on
apprend autrement et d'ailleurs n'a pas
précisé que grande fanfare géante
gyrophare géante mais qu'on dit et ce
sera le dimanche à partir de 13 heures
je crois que thomas la pièce d'eau des
suisses donc à versailles bon je vous
propose qu'on écoute également un
extrait de l'usure
ah bon
alors là donc on a vu différents styles
qu'est ce qu'une bonne fanfare c'est une
question piège et à l'égout la pause
bonbonnes peut enfin je pense que c'est
une fente arc à l'esprit festif et quel
esprit de partage c'est une fanfare
qu'on voit partout on voit dans la rue
qu'on voit dans des festivals et c'est
le sans fard qui fini par organiser un
concours en tout cas rendez vous samedi
et dimanche à versailles
elle est sur site internet peut voir
toute la programmation et les lieux de
rencontre merci beaucoup attendait 3
recèle le musée national de port royal
des champs et le musée de la ville
proposait dimanche dernier une promenade
conférence pour découvrir quatre cents
ans d'histoire locale un reportage de
nottingham berne ce matin là un groupe
de curieux est à la recherche des
reliques perdues de saint quentin
un récit rocambolesque vieux de 400 ans
ces reliques aurait été dissimulée par
un seigneur des environs au xviie siècle
mais un savant trouve une partie de la
clé de l'énigme est en fait un livre un
livre découvert il ya seulement deux ans
et c'est maintenant depuis depuis depuis
peu de temps que l ont transité par ce
territoire qu'elles ont transité par la
ferme de publier qu'elles sont transité
par port royal qu'elles ont peut-être
même transiter par la chapelle qui se
trouvait qui se trouvaient près de près
de l'étang et c'est un petit peu pour
essayer de sortir cette histoire de
l'oubli un parcours organisé autour de
l'histoire locale entre l'étang de saint
quentin et le hameau de bulles loyer je
m'intéresse pas mal à versailles et ça
me permet comme ça de compléter un petit
peu ce que je connais sont versailles
canton j'ai entendu parler de cette
visite les reliques de saint quentin
ça m'a interpellé fectivement donc la
curiosité parce qu'on habite dans le
coin mais
je n'avais jamais entendu parler les
mystères planent toujours sur ces
reliques les historiens cherche à
comprendre ce qu'elle soit devenue un
travail en conséquence on est encore en
train de chercher dans les archives dans
les bibliothèques dans les fonds du
musée de port royal et aussi des fonds
parisien
on est toujours en train de chercher à
compléter l'enquète on continue de
chercher on ne désespère pas de trouver
la localisation exacte de la deuxième
chapelle de trouver encore un certain
nombre de réponses qui restent en
suspens
le musée de la ville de saint quentin en
yvelines propose régulièrement de
remonter le temps une balade à vélo à la
découverte de l'ancien réseau d'étangs
et rigole du roi soleil est d'ailleurs
organisée le 5 juillet nicolas gillet a
rencontré cette semaine sabine caussens
la directrice du prix smile en cours à
nous présente sa nouvelle saison alex
lutz barbara hendricks du jazz de la
danse de l'humour c'est la saison
prochaine au prisme et pour nous en
parler on retrouve qu'il retrouve sa
directrice sabine caussens est tout de
suite dans le kiosque
j'ai dit et par la mer teva zénith
mais étude prêt adultes et une mère on
aime d'un amour des réseaux liés jusqu'à
demain tu vois dans mes rêves est morte
passé un truc de malade aurait fait
perdre mon affaire et est andy park on a
dix sur dix ans confie bercy mais
j'adore mon père ouais j'adore mon père
mais je sais qu'il a l'air sévère mais
il est passé vers toi j'espère en vue de
son immeuble comme un gros nounours tu
me l'as douanes où il passe il a agi par
marie de son 200 250 artistes invités
cette année pour une quarantaine de
spectacles toujours une saine pour la
danse et pour le jazz mais aussi une
bonne présence du théâtre est alors des
spectacles qui sont diversifiées qui
peuvent aller de spectacles connu à des
moins connus alors comme alex lutz par
exemple qui fait une promotion une
ascension fulgurante en ce moment et
puis barbara hendricks par exemple pour
citer quelques noms juliette et puis en
passant par demain dès l'aube
créé par noémie rosenblatt est par
exemple c'est noël tant pis qui sera la
dernière création de pierre note voilà
on voyage entre des écritures
contemporaines sur le théâtre la musique
et la danse
pour la deuxième saison on s'engage sur
une programmation où on essaye d'être à
parité entre les artistes hommes et
femmes femmes et hommes donc l'année
dernière j'avais bien expliqué que
j'étais avec difficulté malgré mes
efforts plutôt je n'y est pas parvenu
cette année nous sommes pas à 50/50 bon
c'est nettement amélioré et j'ai porté
une attention toute particulière à
mettre des femmes à certains endroits
évidemment soutenir leurs créations ça
sera le cas de pauline bureau pour le
spectacle sirènes de noémie rosenblatt
est une jeune metteuse en scène olivia
grandville également une artiste
chorégraphe qu'on va accueillir ici en
résidence et avec lequel on va faire un
grand projet participatif appelé foule
et puis une autre femme que soient pas
toutes les citer un but quand même sur
250 artistes avec difficile
une autre femme auquel je tiens d'un
gène parler c'est anne nguyen qui est
une chorégraphe de danse hip hop mais
également au renvoi le king qui est une
musicienne de jazz religion et qui à qui
j'ai confié la programmation des classes
fleuve c'est cette façon intime
d'écouter du jazz en dehors des scènes
du prisme et mes dents dans le hall et
de façon conviviale
d
dans un cap difficile
nous avons fait une sélection de
spectacles à vivre en famille donc plus
le jeune pub pour le jeune public mais
aussi parents enfants grands parents
frères et soeurs et en faisant une
sélection de spectacles européens alors
l'italie est très grande qualité ces
spectacles l'italie l'espagne les cosses
la tchécoslovaquie la belgique et la
france bien entendu
alors le pôle culturel 17 mars est
quelque chose qui est très important qui
nous réunit déjà depuis deux années ont
fait une programmation donc avec le ciné
7 qui a réouvert ses portes
la médiathèque de cette marque il est
entendu autour du livre et la librairie
17 mars
ensemble on essaye un samedi par mois de
proposer les samedis 17 mar on se
retrouvera pour les nuits blanches qui
sont le 4 octobre au tour de david
rolland et des projets participatifs
toujours pareil avec les habitants mais
le cinéma nous fera une nuit du cinéma
la librairie aura lui aussi des
signatures et des événements dans sa
librairie et la médiathèque 17 mar
également avec des activités tout au
long de la soirée au moins jusqu'à
minuit
l'année prochaine on trouvera un projet
de centre pénitentiaire est un langage
des signes pour arriver à composer
musicalement ensemble ce projet avec
olivia grandville dont je vous parlais
foule à 100 personnes sont painting à
150 personnes et puis je peux pas tous
les citer mais un rendez vous avec
pierre note pour que les amateurs de
théâtre d'écriture théâtrale puisse se
rassembler autour de la compagnie des
gens qui tombent et après le prisme jeu
décrit un cercle sur moi même pour
retrouver celle là qui aime quand tout
est carré aurélia nous sommes mercredi
découvrons à présent vos sorties ciné au
micro d' elodie moines et juliette
poussan j'ai beaucoup aimé parce que
c'est bien joué c'est gai
vraiment on passe un bon moment c'est le
film de détente et c'est pas lourd les
c'est pas lourd comme humour c'est un
bon film très marrant en plus des
acteurs jouent vraiment bien c'est pas
mon super mario lui
idéaliste c'est à conseiller une très
belle histoire bien ficelée de beau
comédien un duo de vaud sauviac super
émouvant ses fins cette élégance c'est
fait d'une façon très comment dirais-je
très très naturel et on a passé un
agréable moment à saint fils de fou
c'est un truc qui pourra pas exister une
jambe au fond me sens mon film de
science fiction aurait vraiment poussé à
son paroxysme complètement surprenant
mais il ya quand même c'est quand même
une bonne histoire
globalement donc voilà ça il ya des
quelques rebondissements mais c'est pas
c'était pas mal
cette semaine le coup de coeur cinéma
est donné par gueye pino responsable du
cinéma le grenier à sel à trappes
bonjour cette semaine au grenier à sel
il y a comme dans les autres cinémas de
france la fête du cinéma c'est du 29
juin au mercredi 2 juillet et toutes les
séances sont à 3 euros 50
et vous pouvez voir plusieurs films tout
ça vous trouverez sur notre site
internet www.cineagde.com mais moi j'ai
surtout envie de vous parler d'un film
qui s'appelle le souffle des dieux c'est
un documentaire sur les origines du yoga
moderne et nous aurons un débat le
vendredi 4 juillet à 20h30
et si donc ici qu'il est le maître des
maîtres tirumala x jeune homme a cherché
un jour je les ai suivis et j'ai
expérimenté une nouvelle fusion du corps
et de l'esprit
alors j'ai voulu savoir d'où venaient
ces exercices et ses postures appelé à
sanaa autre film de à découvrir cette
semaine c'est black hole un film chinois
un polar chinois qui a eu le lion d'or à
berlin
cette année et c'est un vrai renouveau
du cinéma du polar chinois qui utilise
les codes du polar américain avec des
acteurs incroyables et puis surtout avec
une chine qu'on n'a pas l'habitude de
voir et qu'on est bien content de
découvrir sur grand écran des très beaux
paysages sous la neige notamment
l'histoire du film black hole c'est
comme en cent quatre-vingt-dix-neuf un
inspecteur de police découvre des
morceaux de cadavres disséminés dans les
quatre coins de la province et il se
blesse pendant l' enquête
il doit donc arrêter son art son enquête
ici on le retrouve plusieurs années plus
tard cinq ans plus tard et et d'autres
moeurs ont perpétué liés à la même femme
il va donc reprendre l'anc est alors
qu'aujourd'hui les plus policiers et il
est agent de sécurité
ces plaques colle au cinéma le grenier à
sel de bientôt allez je vous propose à
présent d'autres idées de sorties le
photographe unis montrent un julien
duhaime expose jusqu'au 29 juin à la
maison félix de matinée une cinquantaine
de portraits d'artistes les émotions
musicales une exposition qui résume
trois années de concerts la ville de
bois d'arcy organise son festival de
cinéma mémoire des toiles avec pour
thématique cette année la bd au cinéma
rendez vous donc à la ferme de la
tramblais du 27 juin au 5 juillet et
enfin samedi
l'orangerie du château de versailles
accueille à nouveau le grand bal masqué
de kamel ouali tenue d'époque exigé de
20h30 à l'aube un avant de refermer
cette tâche culture je vous propose un
hommage en musique il y a cinq ans jour
pour jour le roi de la pop michael
jackson décédé
petit clin d'oeil à celui que l'on
n'oublie pas à mercredi